- She was standing there like,
this was Keira Knightley's
face the whole time.
She was like--
- [Woman] She ran out and kissed him!
- Yeah, 'cause she was like, "I'm gonna
"peck you on the cheek,
"so you fucking stop this bullshit."
- It's the Holiday Season.
Folks are gathered around
with their families
watching their favorite Holiday movies.
But what is the best Holiday movie?
Some people would say, "Love Actually."
Other people, not so hot on it.
Is Love Actually the new Holiday classic?
It's debatable.
(triumphant orchestral music)
- I'm here to tell you why this is
actually one of the worst movies.
- I love Love Actually.
- Love Actually just gets me angry.
- Love Actually is the best.
- I'm gonna critique the
fuck out of this movie.
(laughing)
(foreboding orchestral music)
Let's start with the
actual film scructure.
- It's barely about Christmas.
Yeah, okay, it's during
Christmas time, whatever.
But it's not like we
sit there and watch them
around a Christmas tree.
- It's like, "Let's get this cavalcade
"of big celebrities,
"throw them in mediocre story lines,
"and then just like get
off on watching people
"happen to cleverly connect at points."
- A lot of the characters
were really creepy.
It wasn't romantic at all.
Like you have that horny Prime Minister--
- He's not that horny!
- He didn't want to
get involved with his secretary.
He found her sexually attractive,
so he fired her.
- I wouldn't be down to clown with that.
I would be like, "This is a little weird,"
and I might be like, "Where is HR?"
- Let's get into this Rick Grimes scene.
This story line is the absolute worst.
The only reason he's using those signs
is because her husband is in the house!
- Imagine you just got married to a guy,
and then your best friend
shows up at your door
with a sign saying,
- Well, the thing is.
- "Don't tell Chloe that
- Then I would never find out,
- I'm here.
because he didn't tell him. (laughs)
- Also, what a terrible
wedding videographer.
You're paid for one thing,
you had one job, Rick Grimes.
Shoot the fucking wedding.
And everything turned into this
creepy-ass closeup of Keira Knightley?
- I would be like, "What the fuck?
"Who are you?"
- You do not lust after
your best friend's girl, especially when
they're getting married.
That's just like, block
that shit off, buddy.
- Then there's this little kid
that decides he's in love with someone
after like pretty much
never speaking to her,
which is fine.
But, he decides to go to the airport--
- You wouldn't be able to run through
any security for that.
- I will say that this is
post-2001, this is post-9/11,
so that kid probly would have been
tased the fuck out of.
- Woah.
(foreboding orchestral music)
- First of all, in Love Actually, you have
one of the best casts ever.
- You never get bored, because
there's always something
different to watch.
- You just feel so many things
in watching this movie.
- Mostly disgust. (chuckles)
- I think it's self-aware, you know?
- I know that some people think that scene
with the guy from The
Walking Dead is creepy.
Yes, it is slightly creepy,
but it is also very romantic,
and he's still being good to his friend,
because he's not trying to
pursue the friend's wife,
he's just trying to let her know
that he doesn't hate her.
- I was a Film major, okay,
I'm appreciating it for what it is.
- It's a frickin' Holiday movie,
like calm down everybody,
it's just a bit of fun.
- Martin Freeman is in it.
He's one of the best people ever
and he's so adorable.
- Isn't he like a sex
stand-in in this movie?
- Yeah.
So?
- A lot of the film is
actually very British-based,
which might be why some
Americans don't really understand it!
- You gotta watch it with Mom.
You gotta watch it with your Mom,
you gotta watch it with your sister.
I don't have a sister, I
just pretend I have one.
- I never watch it any other time
of the year, 'cause
it's a Christmas-y movie
and it gets me in the spirit.
We all cry and laugh and get angry
together about it.
- I also got to hear, "All
I Want For Christmas Is You"
by Mariah Carey in like,
an amazing falsetto voice
and it totally inspired me to sing that
as an 11 year old
at my Christmas party.
- I don't go into Christmas movies
expecting the next Citizen Cane.
But this gave a well-rounded, fun
experience that I can come back to
year after year, and it doesn't get old.
(triumphant orchestral music)
- Basically, all the men
in this movie are trash.
- Oh, you need a closing argument?
- [Woman] Oh my God.
So rude! (laughing)
- Love can be crazy,
the movie shows that.
- Love as it actually is:
weird and messy.
Just let people enjoy themselves.
It's a fun movie.
- Love Actually makes no sense.
There are so many
stories crammed into one.
It's a completely rambling story.
- [Woman] Just like your board.
- In the end, between the
battle of good and evil,
love actually wins.
(triumphant orchestral music)
- [Woman] You were told
seven words or less.
You can't count.
- I just didn't count,
I chose not to.
- Just like you chose
not to like the film.